you want to do yeah I want all the black
guys in this chatroom to whip out their
dick so we can see it please change your
trip
okay I'm gonna hit I'm gonna hit play
right now usually are about to witness
and epic Tyrone Magnus reacts action
I think taro Magnusson the real rejects
may have stumbled upon something maybe
have you to the
shall we
I'm recording it don't worry
I really like the audio situation we
have going on right now it makes it that
much more head notic
we're skipping some stuff
yeah
we're also happy we're also happy
oh my god as much fun as it is watching
me again I are skipping through so
anyone likes Tyrone's jokes it's Tyrone
I see I see pornstar potential that was
great this is one of the best YouTube
days of my life
this really is happy to have you here
baby
Tyrone one day YouTube will most
definitely become your full-time income
that's going to be [ __ ] right I I bet
you have a lot more bills than what I am
but I'm fortunate and I wanted to throw
a thank you out there to subscribers
because this actually become this was
able to replace my job so videos up so
thank you guys so much and it's because
a fun [ __ ] like he's absolutely right I
got some debt we get rid of react if I
need to have the debt that I have it's a
hard job doing this full time they'll be
getting a lot more
from me how hard it is to just be
yourself
yeah this and this has allowed me to do
it
Tojo my my channel has evolved if you
look at my first video introducing time
man you still the world well I'm much
more reserved iron VLAN the channel
there's a subscribe button above me and
you just hit the subscribe button if you
don't have computer
Veronica subscribe but for the mayors
and dads they affiliated with me I need
that exact same subscribe thing but with
like around like midgets imagine Tyrone
subscribe button hit the nail dancers or
also midgets and at one point house he
approves of me
as you should feel Tyron hands are
symbolizing the shape of his penis and
how big it is we get plaques I brought a
game with me Tyrone
Ronnie Jane I brought I recorded all you
guys [ __ ] we did it we watched we
watched most of those minutes all right
I think they can become reactors that
hopefully will see the next time on the
reactor mean we're like you know we're
kind of like Jesus and the disciples
spreading the gospel
in a way but will the reaction just mix
about Ryan that you look like Jesus in a
way I could see that I could see that so
you've been Mary Magdalene oh who did I
just piss off by saying